but uh but he wasn't really a villain i
think aaron sorkin
made sean parker more into a villain
than in my book accidental billionaires
in my book i think sean really has his
eyes on the prize
wants to create a billion dollar company
wants to make a unicorn
and he's got this vision he sees
facebook and says this is it
but he's not really evil um but when you
watch the movie he certainly comes off
as the bad guy
tearing at the relationship between mark
and eduardo um so i think that's a
little bit more what aaron sorkin did
than what i did but
um yeah i find shawn very compelling i
think he's a really smart guy and
i would write about sean again if given
the opportunity but anyways
the winklevoss twins at first to me i i
liked them always but and i respected
them
because they never lie these are guys
who are very much this sort of 1950s
ideal of right and wrong
you don't cheat you don't lie you don't
steal that's all real
this whole men of harvard thing they
really the thing about mark that upset
them the most
was that he lied that he he was
duplicitous that he pretended to work
for them and then didn't
that he created this company behind
their noses when he could have simply
come to them
because they were working together and
they had money um
so he basically cheated them and that to
them is the ultimate sin
um so for them as long as you're honest
and you're telling the truth
they respect you and i respect them for
that but in the story
of the social network they definitely
were the guys who were who were
who were you know the bad guys in a way
um because they were the guys who were
the big
jocks who had this dating website um
that mark
built facebook maybe you know after
seeing their code or whatever but they
were suing him
and you couldn't tell whether it was
right or wrong it wasn't until much
later that i kind of changed my view of
the winklevoss twins
interesting and speaking to that as well
didn't wasn't there uh
some sort of a settlement meeting at a
lawyer's office where mark was freaked
out that those guys were going to
beat the [ __ ] out of them or something
so anyone could go in
yeah this is in my book bitcoin
billionaires this was not on the social
network but
uh basically they had been involved in
this negotiation for a long time
and finally the winklevoss twins said
you know what let's just sit down with
mark
just one on one we're a bunch of college
kids we used to hang out
let's just all get into a room and talk
this out no more lawyers
and so they sent this request over to
mark's lawyers mark's lawyers come back
and say well he agrees in concept but he
has a concern
and it turns out he was concerned they
were going to beat him up
so mark made this rule that only one of
them could come into the meeting
so the meeting took place in this glass
office
with all the lawyers sitting in a circle
around it and
mark met with one window lost with as if
he could take one of them right
right he's gonna fight a six foot five
home remember but anyways they sat
across each other and they kind of
attempted to work it out after that
meeting
mark settled with them for what was
originally 65 million dollars
the twins were not happy with this
agreement so the only way they accepted
it was to accept it in stock
they took they didn't want any cash
their lawyers argued with them and they
ended up getting into a massive argument
with their own lawyers
because their lawyers wanted to take the
65 million in cash
but the twins wanted to be a part of
facebook because they really felt that
they had helped
invent it so they took uh their portion
in cash and in stock and that ended up
being worth half a billion dollars
after the ipo so how did they
originally only get 65 million but
eduardo got five
six billion yeah
eduardo had you know mark had agreed to
eduardo in the very beginning to give
him 30
of facebook okay um that was the
agreement between two college kids in a
dorm room you know there's no lawyers
there's no contracts and so the question
always becomes if you and your buddy
come up with some idea
and then he goes and makes the company
and he builds into this billion dollar
company
what are you uh what do you deserve
and when i ask uh entrepreneurs that
question
they always say you know well
he doesn't really deserve that much but
if you ask venture capitalists that
question they say oh he deserves half
because he was there at the beginning he
put up the money he should get his
percentage
so the settlement was not you know was
based on that
was based on what he was supposed to get
from the very beginning
so mark sort of he sort of did honor his
verbal agreement with him no
he didn't want to um i think the book
made him
i think they really thought they could
stop this book and this movie from
happening
um so i really think the book was the
reason he settled
so the twins after they took their 65
million
in shares with facebook
this is where everything sort of goes to
your story on the bitcoin billionaires
yeah how do these guys become bitcoin
billionaires
yeah so basically uh the winklevoss
twins get this settlement
and they decide they're going to become
a venture capitalist so they're going to
go out
to california and start seeding
companies and they go out there and find
out
no one will take their money because
everyone's end game in silicon valley is
to sell to facebook
and if you have the winklevoss twins you
know on your ledger mark won't buy your
company
and so the winklevoss twins are upset
and so they went to ibiza
to party which is what you do when
you're upset and so they were on the
beach and ibiza and somebody came up to
them and said
um have you guys ever heard of bitcoin
and uh
they had not at the time they didn't
really know anything about it
um bitcoin at the time was a few dollars
you know five ten dollars
um it was a brand new thing and they
looked into it
and were kind of blown away by it and
thinking either this is
total [ __ ] or it's the next big
thing
um and they became convinced it was the
next big thing and then they bought in
hugely they bought two hundred thousand
bitcoin
at around seven dollars a coin so their
goal was to own one percent of all
bitcoin
um and and and part of that story as
well is the person who would come to
them
was an associate of charlie schramm
charlie was one of the
first you know initial bitcoin
entrepreneurs he was an 18 year old kid
living in his parents basement
um who basically uh fell into bitcoin
online as a lot of people at that time
did
uh thought it was cool and started a
website something called bit instant
where you could buy and sell bitcoin
that was the idea
um because at the time to buy bitcoin it
was very hard you had to go through this
weird japanese website called mountain
gox
which was very corrupt which ended up
going out of business after it was
looted
um and uh and there was no good way to
buy bitcoin so charlie started a company
where you could give him money and he
would give you bitcoin it was like a
middleman bitcoin company
and the winklevoss twins were one of his
first
uh they gave him a one and a half
million dollars in financing
um roger ver was his other financer um
roger if you know who he is uh you know
anarchistic libertarian um
he was one of the first bitcoin
investors they used to call him bitcoin
jesus because he had funded so many of
his companies
he's a billionaire as well but he
believed that bitcoin would bring down
governments that bitcoin would bring
down
uh taxes he did not believe in the
military he does not believe the taxes
should happen
he really is a true you know
revolutionary in a way
and so he and the link of us twins are
complete
opposites in how they approach this
world and there was a lot of of tension
between them and ended up being the core
of my book bitcoin billionaires charlie
was in the middle
charlie was a kid who was caught up in
this world of bitcoin
he has the winklevoss twins on one hand
who are the men of harvard they believe
in right and wrong they believe that
bitcoin
should be a financial instrument part of
you know all the different financial
instruments that it should eventually be
on the stock exchange you know as a
commodity basically
and you have roger bear who thinks
bitcoin should take down governments
you should be able to buy drugs if you
want um total freedom anarchy and
libertarianism
and so charlie gets pulled in both
directions meaning like that it should
it should be completely autonomous of
banks or anything like that well they
both
believe that so the cool thing about
bitcoin is there's no middleman there's
no need for a bank there's no need for a
government
there's no need for anybody in between
me and you i can buy and sell bitcoin to
you
without anybody being in between us the
same way i send a text or an email
they all like that but what roger ver
believes is that
there should be no regulations it should
be basically silk road all the time
you want to go buy drugs on silk road go
buy drugs on silk road
you don't want to pay taxes keep your
money in bitcoin no one pay taxes
and that's not the way the winklevoss
twins see it they see it as something
that should have some level of
regulation
so that it's safe that bitcoin will
never be popular unless
my mother can use bitcoin you know
without worrying
that it's gonna you know get stolen or
that she's gonna get attacked by the irs
or
you know something like that so they
believe that bitcoin needs to
get away from the sort of cowboy past um
the idea that it's just for criminals
and things like that as opposed to
someone like roger ver
who believes that bitcoin was made to be
anonymous because it gives you the
powers that anonymity gives you
um the ability to sort of not be
involved in the real world and not have
a government looking over your shoulder
um to not pay taxes for instance um and
that's a very different way of looking
at it
so what are the tw what are the uh
winkle by
winklevoss twins doing today in regards
to the wink of lost twins you know
are billionaires because of this
investment um they have launched
something called gemini which is an
exchange
where you can buy and sell bitcoin um
it's regulated
it's part of the new york financial uh
sort of
network over there it's it's uh
guaranteed so you don't have to worry
about your money
um so gemiini is their main project and
they're also proselytizers they travel
the world
promoting bitcoin explaining why it's
the money of the future
um there's a big question of whether
it's a commodity or whether it's a
currency
is it going to be like gold something
you grab and hold on to
and increases in value or is it going to
be something that you use to buy and
sell things
right now for the most part it's like
gold um but better because
you can carry it around on your phone um
it's not something
somewhere and it's instantly
transferable so i can send you a bitcoin
i can't send you a piece of gold it's
not something you can touch
right it's not but it exists so it's
kind of this weird thing
where it's both virtual and physical
because you actually carry it around
with you
um but it doesn't really exist anywhere
um so yes
it's an interesting sort of phenomena
but what do you mean you can carry it
around with you like meaning that it's
like it's stored just like a like a file
on your computer
except for it's not in your computer um
so you get a hash you get a specific
address where your bitcoin is and you
have a code
to get your bitcoin and that's all you
have so that
that code is your bitcoin um your
bitcoin isn't held anywhere there's
something called the blockchain
so when you exchange bitcoin that is
logged onto this thing called the
blockchain which is like this virtual
brick wall
and each brick is connected to the other
brick connected to the other brick